écoutez bien cette prévision effarante
si rien n'est fait pour les sauver 500
millions d'hommes vont mourir de faim
d'ici à l'an 2000 ce n'est pas un
nouveau nostradamus mais les enquêteurs
des nations unies qu'il dise on comprend
dans ces conditions l'importance de la
conférence mondiale de l'alimentation
qui va s'ouvrir demain à rome
pendant dix jours les délégués de 150
pays vont chercher les moyens de lutter
contre un fléau dont les occidentaux
n'ont pas encore pris suffisamment
conscience la famille en 1974 dans le
monde
un demi milliard d'hommes et d'enfants
ont cruellement souffert de la faim les
uns en sont morts les autres en
resteront définitivement diminuer ces
hommes qui sont ils de petits
exploitants sans terre ou sans emploi
des miséreux dans les taudis des grandes
villes où vivent t-il sur ce panis faire
les zones de la faim apparaissant plus
clair c'est en contemplant une carte
comme celle ci que l'on a pu parler de
géographie de la faim ou mieux encore de
géopolitique de la faim ce qui engage
plus directement la responsabilité de
l'homme
il peut paraître inimaginable
inacceptable que l'humanité après des
siècles de progrès technologique n'est
plus encore maîtrisé ce fléau il
imaginable inacceptable quand on sait
que ces foyers de faim chronique se
situe à quelques heures d'avion de nos
pays refuse et gaspilleur indifférence
et là c'est avec la conférence de rome
le réveil sera brutal égoïstement
parlant en effet la crise alimentaire a
pris de telles proportions depuis 1972
que les pays dits développés seront
également touchés en 1972 que s'est il
donc passé
la production céréalière mondiale s'est
effondré pour satisfaire les besoins
il fallait accroître la production de 25
millions de tonnes
le déficit de plus de 33 millions de
tonnes pour certains pays l explication
est d'ordre météorologiques mauvaises
récoltes en urss en chine en inde en
australie au sahel dans d'autres pays
etats unis notamment
il s'agit de politique réduction
volontaire de la production en 1973 la
situation ne s'est pas améliorée bien au
contraire car aux méfaits du mauvais
temps se sont ajoutés ceux de la
stabilité monétaire et de la spéculation
les prix des céréales ont quadruplé
cette année on attendait d'une récolte
abondante il faudra déchanter les
dernières estimations sont très
pessimistes
le résultat de ces trois années de
pénurie le voici la diminution
catastrophique des stocks des pays
exportateurs des réserves pour quelques
pauvres semaines de consommation
les experts des nations unies lancent un
cri d'alarmé dans leur rapport ils
écrivent il est douteux qu'une crise
alimentaire et jamais pris de
proportions mondiales comme aujourd'hui
la planète se trouve brusquement en
butte à une incertitude inacceptable
hélas il ne s'agit pas d'abstraction à
dacca au bangladesh
vingt personnes meurent de faim chaque
jour et depuis les inondations de
juillet la famine a fait des milliers de
morts en inde une spéculation honteuse
est venue se greffer sur ces calamités
naturelles pour tout le sous continent
indien
le double problème de l'insuffisance des
stocks et de l'augmentation des prix
prend donc un caractère particulièrement
tragique mais attention ne parlons pas
de fatalité d'incompétence de mauvaise
volonté dans les pays sous développés la
production agricole s'est accrue plus
vite que dans les pays hautement
industrialisés
les hommes de là bas on travaillait dur
autant que leur permet leur
sous-alimentation
seulement voilà le mauvais temps l
explosion démographique l'augmentation
du prix des produits en provenance des
pays industrialisés et le manque de
solidarité internationale
cela fait beaucoup et si rien ne change
les années à venir seront plus sombre
encore pendant dix jours à rome
les représentants des 150 pays devront
se prononcer sur le programme d'urgence
des nations unies un programme en trois
points
augmenter la production dans les pays en
voie de développement
des milliers d'hectares de bonnes terres
ne sont toujours pas cultiver en
amérique latine notamment sur le
continent africain il faudrait augmenter
et les rendements par une meilleure
utilisation de l'eau et des engrais à
condition toutefois de ne pas buter sur
les seuils écologique et de mieux
informer l'agriculteur de base garantir
les approvisionnements par la
constitution de stocks mondiaux et la
stabilisation des prix
un grand nombre de pays en développement
devront recevoir une aide continue à des
conditions de faveur
enfin améliorer la distribution et la
qualité des aliments
à l'évidence il s'agit là d'un problème
financier donc politique à rome se
heurteront comme toujours les
initiatives l'opposé de la
susceptibilité du profit et des
rivalités mais ce premier pas il faut le
franchir ensemble pour que disparaissent
sur la carte du monde ces tâches indigne
pour que cesse le scandale de la faim